en el problema anterior nos quedamos
resolviendo este sistema terminamos de
encontrar cuál era la aceleración neta
de todo este sistema de dos masas y una
polea que terminan moviéndose hacia la
derecha bueno en esta ocasión lo que
quiero es bueno terminar de hacer un
cálculo más y vamos a ver otro problema
que yo creo que les va a parecer
bastante divertido pero este otro
problema es qué pasa si yo quiero saber
cuál es la atención en este cable
bueno ya recordamos que el último que
encontramos es que todo el sistema se
estaba acelerando a este rango 4.13
metros por segundo al cuadrado
y bueno ustedes pueden pensar cómo puedo
encontrar la atención de este objeto si
todo sistema se está moviendo hacia la
derecha bueno debemos pensar en
contemplar esto de la siguiente manera
vamos a tomar solo una parte de este
sistema digamos que lo único que podemos
ver es esta masa de 20 kilos que está
suspendida de un cable y también sabemos
que esta masa de 20 kilos no está
acelerándose tanto como lo haría de no
tener el cable se está acelerando a sólo
4.3 en metros por segundo al cuadrado y
si estuviera suelta se aceleraría con la
aceleración de la gravedad que es de 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado
entonces este cable debe estar
ejerciendo una fuerza hacia arriba
sobre este objeto y esa fuerza es la
detención es lo que estamos
lo que está moderando la aceleración
deteniendo la de 9.8 a 4.3 metros por
segundo al cuadrado
esencialmente cuál es la fuerza neta
sobre este objeto y solamente sobre este
objeto no vamos a tomar en cuenta esto
que he escrito en este lado
y bueno sabemos que la fuerza en este
objeto
vamos a escribir
a la fuerza
en este objeto es igual a su masa por la
aceleración en este caso es la
aceleración
que tiene este sistema que está detenido
por el cable las vibraciones de 4.13
metros por segundo el cuadrado hacia
abajo y esto es aproximadamente
83 newtons hacia abajo esa es la fuerza
en este en esta parte en este objeto mi
fuerza aquí
la fuerza de y de igual a 83 newtons
hacia abajo
y también sabemos que la fuerza de
tensión se calcula de esta manera
la tensión
más la fuerza de gravedad que en este
caso es el peso del objeto
va a ser igual a la
fuerza normal que es la fuerza que va
hacia arriba que está ejerciendo se
sobre este cable
entonces bueno la atención todavía no lo
sabemos pero sabemos que la atención es
una fuerza que va en dirección hacia
arriba y la fuerza de gravedad va hacia
abajo
entonces vamos a poner números tenemos
que el peso de este objeto la fuerza de
gravedad de este objeto es de 196
newtons
entonces lo escribimos aquí tensión más
la fuerza de gravedad que 196 newtons es
igual a la fuerza normal y la fuerza
normal vimos en esta
ocasión bueno sabemos que es la fuerza
en dirección opuesta a la fuerza del
movimiento la fuerza de la gravedad
calculamos que nuestra fuerza es de 83
newtons entonces la fuerza normal pas es
de 83 minutos
y vamos a despejar este este valor
son 83 minutos
la fuerza de gravedad va hacia abajo y
estos 83 minutos de la fuerza normal van
hacia arriba las vamos a jugar con los
signos para indicar cuando van hacia
arriba y hacia abajo las fuerzas tenemos
la fuerza de tensión es igual a
menos 196 más 83
es igual a menos
113 minutos el menos indica que va hacia
arriba
entonces
esta es la atención del cable
113 newtons hacia arriba
que está soportando está cable de esta
parte del sistema igual podríamos haber
seleccionado esta parte de nuestro
sistema total para calcular la atención
sobre este cable con luisa bueno
involucrando todas las fuerzas que están
actuando en esta parte y nos hubiera
salido exactamente el mismo valor
pero ahora vamos a comenzar con otro
problema más sencillo y divertido
permítanme limpiar la pantalla bueno en
este problema
yo tengo un pastel
voy a dibujarlo aquí
tengo 1 pastel
no sé digamos qué es
de limón
y lo estoy sosteniendo con mi mano
entonces bueno algo así como mi mano
verdad
y lo que quiero hacer mi objetivo es que
este pastel
llegué
al rostro de esta persona
pues por alguna razón a lo mejor no se
nos hizo enojar
este o simplemente
es un maniquí de estos de
pruebas que no sienten nada pero bueno
por alguna razón quiero darle un
pastelazo a la cara a esa persona
y lo que quiero yo calcular es con qué
fuerza tengo yo que a acelerar o qué en
qué rapidez tengo que yo lanzar este
pastel para que no se caiga al suelo y
dé en el rostro de esta persona
bueno
que es tan rápido debo empujar este
pastel
ahora bueno yo sé aunque ustedes no
saben pero yo sé que el coeficiente de
fricción entre mi mano y este pastel es
de punto 8 mi coeficiente de fricción es
de punto 8
y bueno digamos que el pastel tiene una
masa
llamada m es igual a masa
del pastel y bueno la fuerza de gravedad
pues va a estar actuando hacia abajo
cuál es la fuerza de gravedad que jala
este pastel hacia abajo
bueno la fuerza de gravedad va a ser
igual a la masa que todavía no sé cuál
es la masa de este pastel por la
aceleración de la gravedad que es
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
esta es una multiplicación x
para que este país no se caiga que
debemos lo que sabemos acerca de las
fuerzas netas sobre este pastel sabemos
que las fuerzas metas en este pastel
deben ser igual a cero
entonces cuál va a ser la fuerza
compensatoria la fuerza compensatoria es
la que va a obtenemos que estar a
segundo que actúe
compensando la fuerza de gravedad para
que éste no cayera
bueno la fuerza de fricción es lo que va
a hacer nuestra fuerza compensatoria
nuestra fuerza de fricción va a ir hacia
arriba recuerden que la fricción siempre
va a ir en contra del movimiento de
nuestro objeto
esencialmente la fuerza de fricción debe
ser mayor a la fuerza de gravedad bueno
mayor o igual porque si fuera mayor pues
uno pensaría que se iría hacia arriba
del pastel y recuerden que bueno la
fricción nunca va a mover algo solo se
va a oponer al movimiento si el
coeficiente de fricción es 08 cuanto
esfuerzo tengo que aplicar bueno vamos a
calcular la fuerza de fricción tenemos
nuestra fórmula de fricción la fuerza de
fricción es igual
9.82 jamás
no miento miento estoy mal ok no me
hagan caso a la fuerza de fricción
obviamente tiene que involucrar el
coeficiente de fricción nos vamos a
quitar esto
ahora si la fuerza de fricción es igual
a el coeficiente de fricción por la
fuerza normal la fuerza normal la fuerza
compensatoria es la fuerza que en este
caso
va a ser perpendicular
a
esta superficie que está
supongamos o recordando los problemas
que hemos visto antes de la superficie
inclinada y el objeto encima bueno
imagínense que mi mano es la esta
superficie inclinada y esta es la fuerza
normal del objeto en este caso del
pastel
y bueno esta fuerza te va a ser igual
a la masa por la aceleración recordamos
que esto las fuerzas totales la fuerza
neta debe ser igual a cero entonces esta
fuerza normal tiene que ser la misma que
la fuerza de gravedad sólo que en este
caso en este otro sentido entonces
sustituimos la fuerza de fricción
tenemos que es nuestro coeficiente 0.8
y la fuerza normal
y tenemos que
nuestra fuerza
en este caso de este lado 9.8 por la
masa entonces cuál va a ser nuestra
fuerza normal la fuerza normal es
despejamos esto
9.8 entre 0.8
por la masa bueno estoy usando
mayúsculas y minúsculas pero me estoy
refiriendo a la masa del pastel
y tenemos entonces que la fuerza normal
la fuerza con la que yo tengo que
aventar esto hacia el rostro o moverlo
9.8 entre 0.8 ya hice mi cálculo aparte
y es igual a
12.25 por la masa
entonces bueno no sé cuál es la masa del
país pero sé que cualquiera que sea la
masa que éste tenga yo tengo que
multiplicar a incrementar esa masa 12 o
esa fuerza con la masa 12.25 veces para
tener la fuerza normal suficiente para
evitar que o compensar la fuerza de
gravedad evitar que el pastel caiga y
vaya directo en esta dirección y ahora
qué tan rápido voy a estar acelerando el
pay o el pastel
recordamos nuestra fórmula de fuerza es
igual a masa por aceleración
la fuerza la tengo aquí
establecida como 12.25 por la masa igual
a la masa que sigue siendo la misma masa
de este pastel por la aceleración
quiero dejarlo despejar la aceleración
esto termino de multiplicar acá lo paso
dividiendo y se anula con este y me
queda que la aceleración es de 12.25
metros por segundo al cuadrado así que
tengo que aplicar una aceleración
12.25 metros por segundo al cuadrado que
es mayor que la aceleración de la
gravedad que también la aceleración de
la gravedad
cuando es el mismo valor se también se
le llama como 1 g entonces esta
aceleración tiene que ser mayor a un g
recordamos que la aceleración de la
gravedad es 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y aquí son 12.25 metros por
segundo al cuadrado así que tengo que
empujar lo más rápido que un g para que
la fuerza normal proporcione una
fricción tal que es evite que el país
caiga si el suelo y logra alcanzar la
cara de esta persona los veo en el
siguiente vídeo